[Music]
welcome back to science click today what
would we see if we approach the speed of
light
let's Embark together on a spaceship
which accelerates away from Earth
moving faster and faster
what would we see when constantly
accelerating
what Optical effects would occur
and if we try to exceed light speed by
bending space-time like in Sci-Fi movies
what would we see
answering these questions will lead us
to explore many fascinating phenomena of
our universe
and immerse ourselves at the heart of
special and general relativity
our spacecraft is initially at rest
once launched we begin to accelerate
we imagine that its propulsion system
allows us to accelerate constantly as
long as we wish
as we gain speed we move away from Earth
by accelerating more and more one would
think that the speed would eventually
become unbearable
however this is not the case speed has
no effect on our body
when two trains cross it is impossible
to feel whether it is our train or the
other which is at rest
similarly inside the spaceship we cannot
feel its speed but only its acceleration
the thrust of the reactors which presses
us against our seats
if this thrust is reasonable it will be
perfectly bearable all along our journey
even When approaching the speed of light
there is nonetheless a risk associated
with very high speeds a collision
at High Velocity a mere Speck of dust
would cause colossal damage if it hit us
fortunately our ship is equipped with a
force field that repels dangerous
objects and allows us to roam freely
through space
as we accelerate a first Optical effect
appears
the stars in front of us which we get
closer to seem to gradually move away
the sky contracts before us
to understand think of this common
situation
you are in a car driving at high speed
and it starts to rain
the rain falls vertically from top to
bottom
but as the car moves forwards you
receive raindrops on the windshield from
face on
the rain does not appear to fall from
above but from the front as if its
trajectory were tilted and the more you
accelerate the more the rain seems to
come from face on
our spaceship the optical effect is
perfectly analogous the stars is light
comes from a certain direction but as we
accelerate the light rays appeared to
come more and more from the front their
Direction seems different when we are in
motion
this is the aberration of light
as light focuses in front of us its
intensity increases
while behind us the sky seems to widen
and becomes darker
the aberration of light results in
another strange phenomenon
let's imagine we are moving through an
immense grid representing the fabric of
space
ordinarily we would see a straight grid
made up of straight lines converging in
front of us due to perspective
however by speeding up the aberration
phenomenon distorts the image of the sky
around us as the days go by the grid
seems to contract forward and the
straight lines Bend
if we were to go past an object it would
appear to be slightly angled in our
Direction
this is called terrible Penrose rotation
as we move very quickly images of
objects seem contracted in front of us
and perspective is strongly distorted
[Music]
we often hear that the further we look
into space the further we look into the
past
indeed the light we receive from a
distant star must travel billions of
kilometers this journey is not
instantaneous and it takes some time for
light to reach us
as a result we see the star as it was in
the past when it emitted this light
perhaps several thousand years ago who
knows how it might have changed since
then
looking out from our spaceship the same
phenomenon is at work as we move away
from Earth the planet's light takes
longer and longer to reach us
if we could zoom in with a telescope we
would see people on Earth evolving in
slow motion
this is the Doppler effect each tick of
the clocks on Earth takes longer and
longer to reach us we receive light rays
in slow motion and their intensity seems
to weaken as the image of the planet
shifts towards red color
in front of us it's the opposite effect
the ship catches up with the light and
the Stars seem to get brighter they
shift towards blue color and their
clocks seem to take faster
[Music]
with precise enough equipment we could
measure the aberration and Doppler
effects since the start of our
acceleration in space
however if we decided to end our journey
and return to Earth these effects would
have had no impact
they are only optical illusions due to
the way we receive light while moving
after several hundred days however as
the reactors push us ever faster the
ship begins to approach light speed
at such speeds some phenomena will no
longer be mere optical illusions real
physical effects will kick in with
irreversible consequences
special relativity comes into play
a first consequence of Relativity is
known as time dilation
our universe is a huge four-dimensional
fabric called space-time made up of
three dimensions of space and one
dimension of time
inside space-time all bodies trace a
trajectory since they all Advance
towards their future
for takeoff our ship was moving in the
same way as Earth towards the future
but by picking up speed and zooming away
from Earth faster and faster our
trajectory gradually deviated from that
of the planet
the axis we call time is no longer
aligned with the time axis of people on
earth
if we decided to turn around and come
back our clocks would have measured a
different time and we would have aged
less than earthlings because our
trajectories in space-time would have
been different
[Music]
another key consequence of special
relativity is called length contraction
when a body moves it close to light
speed its length gets contracted in the
direction of its motion
from the spaceship's perspective the
entire universe is moving backwards for
us the universe is contracted along our
direction of motion as such the length
of the journey to reach our destination
is shorter than expected
we are not talking about Optical effects
anymore but of a physical and concrete
phenomenon if we tried to reach a
distant star the journey would genuinely
seem shorter to us it would take less
and less time the faster we move
thus contrary to popular misconception
it is in fact possible to travel
thousands of light years in just a few
seconds
and in the case where we would move
almost at light speed the journey would
even seem instantaneous to us
for the people on Earth however several
thousand years would have passed
[Music]
length contraction is a very real
phenomenon however visually it would be
difficult to see
to understand why imagine that we
crossed the orbit of a planet
as it moves very quickly towards us the
planet's length is contracted
but remember the farther we look into
space the farther we look into the past
and from our perspective the back of the
planet is located further in space than
the front of the planet
the image that we receive from the back
of the planet has taken longer to reach
us so we see it as it was in the past
even if it is contracted the planet does
not look like it because we receive the
image of its back with a delay
rather than contracted it appears to be
rotated this is a phenomenon we have
already seen Terrell Penrose rotation
when we move very fast and look to our
side the edges of the object around us
seem shorter in the direction of motion
this can be interpreted either as length
contraction or as a rotation as a change
in perspective
for the same reason a person watching us
Zoom by would not really see our ship
contracted but rather rotated on itself
[Music]
over time our field of view continues to
contract it intensifies in front of us
while going completely black behind us
by accelerating more and more we would
perhaps expect to reach the speed of
light at some point what would we see
then
this question might be one of the most
fundamental in relativity
the answer is no even if the ship
accelerates constantly we will never
reach the speed of light
that is because the speed of light is
absolute you may try to catch a light
Ray but from your point of view it will
always Escape at the same speed the
speed of light
you may accelerate as much as you wish
even if from Earth you would seem to
approach the speed of light from your
point of view you are still motionless
and light escapes inexorably
[Music]
in short it is strictly impossible to
exceed or even reach the speed of light
at best our ship will continue to
accelerate forever and our field of
vision will continue to shrink ever more
until forming an infinitely bright spot
in front of us surrounded by a
completely black sky
almost at light speed all Optical
effects would become extreme
as we catch up with light rays before us
they all seem to come from the front
meanwhile the Rays behind us can never
reach us
in our frame of reference the universe
would be extremely contracted like a
thin fabric that we would cross from
side to side in a fraction of a second
for a person on Earth we'd be moving at
the speed of light
but for us the trip seems instantaneous
we move infinitely fast
to conclude nothing can ever move faster
than light through space
but there might be a way to circumvent
this rule
in fact nothing prohibits space itself
from moving faster than light
indeed the theory of general relativity
teaches us that the fabric of space-time
is dynamic it can bend in multiple ways
we could thus imagine creating a bubble
around our spaceship which we would
Propel faster than light
this is called a warp drive in reference
to science fiction
it would no longer be a matter of
zooming a vehicle through space but of
propelling the fabric of space itself
our ship would remain motionless surfing
on a wave of faster than light
space-time
such a structure may seem absurd and
indeed it is currently thought to be
impossible to achieve
producing a warp drive would require
bending space time with huge amounts of
negative Mass a form of matter that does
not seem to exist in our universe
that said mathematics still allow us to
model and calculate what we would see in
such a situation
if we looked from outside the warp drive
would seem to appear out of nowhere
the curvature of space-time deviates the
trajectory of light rays forming a
moving lens which splits into two one
part moving forwards and the other
retreating in the opposite direction
light travels slower than the warp drive
itself when it approaches light has not
yet had the time to reach us
and after it crosses us we receive both
the light which had not yet reached us
and the rays which were emitted later
looking from the inside of the warp
drive we would see the sky contracted in
front of us and very bright
behind us the universe would look
extremely dark and a whole patch of the
sky would simply vanish from our view
the light emitted from there is too slow
to catch up with us a cone of the
universe remains permanently invisible
[Music]